okay admit it you're sick of congressman
adam kinziger
okay because he wants to lead the gop
away from trumpism
and back to the good old days when
neocons and the chamber of commerce
cronies
ran the party and sold out american
workers but is this something that the
voters actually want well you know the
answer
my next guest doesn't think so and is
launching a primary challenge
against the illinois rep
i never thought i'd primary a fellow
republican but is congressman adam
kinzinger really a republican anymore
this is adam kinzinger a weak need
establishment republican who cares more
about his next
msnbc appearance than the voters who
elected him
scorcher catalina lauf illinois
congressional candidate joins me now
catalina good to see you
uh congressman kinziger has won
comfortably in your district for a few
cycles now
uh so i mean he outperformed president
trump
uh in the last election by i think about
10 points or so
so why do you think this is an
opportunity to
unseat him you know thanks for having me
on laura you know the the voters and the
constituents
clearly i didn't know who he was you
know the last
few months here he's been prancing
around msnbc
bashing uh former president trump not
actually doing any work for
the constituents and so i'm really
excited to be able to really
uncover uh the lack of servant
leadership
that he has been delivering for the
constituents it's time that we hold
people like adam kinzinger accountable
you know they are
not doing what we hired them to do uh
and studies using taxpayer money to go
on
all these liberal media shows yeah i
want to play some of that i want to
play some of that catalina because he's
he's
very comfortable when he's in
a friendly forum on cable news watch
what we've had for the last four years a
president that's focused on division
stark is stoking the darkness in
everybody's heart
anger and fear and stoking division
that's what has to
end and nobody can call that out like
somebody in their own party
and of course catalina the media is
reciprocating that love
we gotta tip our hat to adam kinzinger
he is really being outspoken about this
but
other than that the uh the courageous
caucus is a very small caucus indeed
i'd like adam kinzinger to come to my
house for brunch but you also have to
figure out why you're such a rare animal
you know i was talking about you
um this weekend one of my favorite
pastimes oh love is in the air catalina
well
again doesn't this just confirm that
kinziger
is more in touch with the democrats than
he is with
the republican party absolutely and he's
playing into
exactly what the me the left-wing media
wants him to play into which is
that the republican party is going
through the civil war
that we're rejecting trumpism i mean
he's becoming the poster child of that
you know where was adam when blm was
destroying
uh the suburbs of illinois where was
adam when our governor
jb pritzker was sitting there
politicizing the kobit 19 response
why wasn't he encouraging small
businesses back home
you know he's totally comfortable with
getting money from
bill gates who believes that we should
be eating synthetic beef
you know how what do the illinois 16
farmers think about that
you know this is just it's
ridiculousness and frankly people have
had enough
i think the way to grow the gop is
through conservative
hispanics people who care about small
business and
freedom and religious liberty and
catalina i'm very excited about this
we'll be watching it really closely
thanks so much for
joining us